Hello, one and all, and welcome back to the
Anom-O-Tron 6000.
Our patented device for projecting any seemingly
improbable scenario for your viewing indulgence.
And today, we decided to do something slightly
different with it.
Here at SCP Explained, we usually activate
the Anom-O-Tron to bring you encounters between
the anomalous denizens of the SCP Universe
and other fictional characters, like Doctor
Strange fighting the Scarlet King, or Able
crossing paths with Batman.
But this Anom-O-Ton experiment is one of our
more unusual, to say the least.
If you’ve been subscribed to us for a while,
some of you might remember our video ‘What
If SCP-096 Was Put Inside SCP-914?’.
In it, the Shy Guy was tricked into entering
the Input booth of the anomalous refinement
machine during a containment breach.
What emerged was maybe the handsomest man
to ever live, beautiful both on the outside
and within.
A lot of our comments pointed out that this
refined version of 096 felt akin to a ‘Giga
Chad’, and that got us thinking; what if
SCP-096 was to encounter the real Giga Chad?
Well, the Anom-O-Tron 6000 has a few different
answers for us.
Scenario One – or as we like to call it,
‘The Obvious Outcome’ – pits the thin,
humanoid anomaly against the man behind the
meme.
Ernest Khalimov is a Russian fitness trainer
and model, forever immortalized in the annuls
of internet history by a series of black and
white photoshopped pictures that garnered
him the nickname of ‘Giga Chad’.
Thanks to his practically perfect ninety-degree
jawline and muscular physique, Khalimov seemingly
unknowingly became the archetype for an ultra-masculine,
handsome man.
However, the man behind the Giga Chad meme
is still, just a man.
The infamous photos of him were heavily edited
for an art project known as Sleek’N’Tears,
and while Ernest does sport some impressive
muscles from all his time at the gym, that
strength isn’t enough to save him from the
Shy Guy.
After all, he’s still just a man.
According to the Anom-O-Tron’s predictions,
the most likely outcome if the two were ever
to meet would end pretty similarly to the
grim fate of many others who have gazed upon
the face of SCP-096.
The moment Ernest looks at the creature, he
would – in all likelihood – activate SCP-096’s
rage state.
His physique and above-average level of fitness
might give him a slight advantage, allowing
him to perhaps outrun the Shy Guy for longer
than most.
But ultimately, Ernest Khalimov would be able
to run, but not hide, from SCP-096.
The creature would track him down and home
in on him with anomalous speed, dispatching
him before returning to its usual, docile
sobbing state.
The result?
An SCP-096 victory.
Now, we know what you’re thinking.
Is that really it?
We had the same reaction too, but hold on
for a minute.
After giving the machine an additional set
of variables, we were able to get a few more
interesting outcomes out of the Anom-O-Tron.
Which brings us to the result that we’ve
given the title of ‘Scenario Two: Shy Harder’.
Of course, Ernest Khalimov might be the face
of an internet meme, and ultimately just a
very strong Russian man in comparison to the
anomalous traits of SCP-096.
But the Giga Chad?
The Giga Chad is more than a man, so much
more than the sum of his parts.
Existing within the online zeitgeist since
as early as 2017, the Giga Chad is far more
powerful than a mere mortal.
He doesn’t just represent idealized standards
of over-exaggerated masculinity like the action
movie heroes of the 1980s; the Giga Chad embodies
those ideas.
He is the very notion of a physically perfected
human specimen given form.
You may not like it, but peak performance
doesn’t even come close to the Giga Chad.
And neither does SCP-096; even at the top
of its game, the creature quite literally
pales in comparison to its imposing opponent.
In Scenario Two: Shy Harder, the Anom-O-Tron
6000 predicted that, if the two were to meet,
the scales would tip in the complete opposite
direction from the first outcome.
For that was SCP-096 against the man, but
against the meme himself – well, this fight
is no contest.
As a matter of fact, it’s hardly even a
fight – certainly not a fair one – and
instead is more of an execution.
From the moment the unstoppable tower of muscle
and perfect angular jawline that is the Giga
Chad claps eyes on SCP-096, it’s practically
the beginning of the end.
The Shy Guy doesn’t even lift, bro – but
Giga Chad can bench one million times his
own bodyweight in his sleep.
So, when SCP-096 comes racing towards him,
intent on killing him just for looking at
its screeching, wide-jawed face, the Giga
Chad does what the Giga Chad does best: he
lifts.
Grabbing SCP-096 with ease as it comes at
him screeching, Giga Chad casually hoists
the creature off the ground.
Although he’s only using the tiniest portion
of his immense and infinite strength, it’s
more than enough force to send the Shy Guy
soaring upwards, crashing through multiple
ceilings as it’s sent hurtling up the numerous
floors of the Foundation facility above.
Of course, being lifted is hardly going to
kill the Shy Guy outright – the creature
is known to be invulnerable, after all.
But it’s not like the Giga Chad can go down
easily either.
Don’t forget, this is no mere mortal, but
an internet meme incarnate.
And on the internet, nothing ever dies.
His perpetual existence as part of online
history aside, the Giga Chad is so strong
that no doubt his abs could withstand the
firepower of any conventional weapon.
Realizing that, even if it could reach him,
it couldn’t even scratch the Giga Chad,
SCP-096 would undoubtedly begin a downward
spiral.
The Shy Guy is a creature so insecure in itself
and its appearance that it kills anyone who
so much as glances at its face in photos,
so being presented with the living embodiment
of an idea it could never even hope to attain
– the biceps, the perfect right-angled jawline
– it’s all too much.
Sending SCP-096 into a complete meltdown,
the creature would be neutralized once and
for all by the very existence of the Giga
Chad; resulting in his victory.
Okay, so we’re one point to SCP-096, and
one to Giga Chad, and most people would maybe
consider leaving it there.
But not us, we wanted more than that.
You see, we quickly realized that the Anom-O-Tron’s
second scenario was based on a lot of earlier
iterations of the Giga Chad meme.
Don’t get us wrong, that version of the
ultimate man could still easily destroy the
Shy Guy.
But around March of 2021, the infamous photoshopped
images of Ernest Khalimov started to be used
in slightly different formats.
That’s the thing about memes, they’re
not only immortal, forever logged in the ancient
texts of the Way Back Machine and compilation
videos here on YouTube.
But they’re also adaptable, they can evolve
and change, finding new variations as time
goes on.
As such, the ‘Average Fan Vs Average Enjoyer’
meme saw a new use of the Giga Chad.
Before, the Giga Chad, this notion of the
ideal, ultra-masculine specimen was based
on – let’s be honest – some pretty outdated
ideas about what it means to be a man.
After all, it takes more than muscle to be
a man, not every man – or masculine-presenting
person – has to work out until they’re
built like a brick wall.
Perhaps the real measure of a man is how sincere,
sensitive, and supportive you can be, as well
as standing by your interests rather than
caving to old societal standards of masculinity.
And, after we updated our data, the Anom-O-Tron
6000 was able to give us a new, revised outcome.
Or, was we liked to call Scenario Three: ‘The
Average SCP-096 Enjoyer’.
In this projection, the Giga Chad’s true
strength isn’t just his muscular physique
and his unattainable standards.
Instead, it’s – in part – the inherent
adaptability of his status as a meme, but
also his compassion.
Just like before, he’s more than able to
resist SCP-096’s attacks, and the creature’s
insecurity comes out, put on full display
when presented with Giga Chad’s sharp jawline.
But rather than overcome his anomalous adversary
by fighting him, this scenario sees the Giga
Chad comforting the Shy Guy.
Through calm empathy and words of affirmation,
he reminds SCP-096 that true acceptance of
oneself comes from within, and that message
strikes a chord with the creature.
In a turn of events none of us saw coming,
the Giga Chad offers to help SCP-096 overcome
his crippling – and deadly – sense of
insecurity.
The pair start using the on-site gym together
– after hours when there aren’t any innocent
Foundation personnel around.
There, Giga Chad not only offers to introduce
SCP-096 to an exercise regime if it’s what
the creature wants, but also helps the Shy
Guy work on his confidence.
They form a friendship, with SCP-096 taking
a liking to working out; not because it wants
to be buff like its new friend the Giga Chad,
but more so because doing so makes it feel
more comfortable in its own skin.
SCP-096 gradually starts to like itself more,
even eating healthier thanks to Giga Chad’s
advice.
Eventually, the Shy Guy begins looking far
more content and even starts to develop self-confidence,
thanks to the Giga Chad’s patience, understanding
and support for his homie.
The result is a tie.
Pretty wholesome, right?
After using the Anom-O-Tron almost exclusively
for death matches between SCPs and other fictional
characters, it’s a nice change of pace to
get one with a happy ending.
And that got us thinking, it’s not often
that a story involving SCP-096 exists with
the creature getting to achieve some semblance
of happiness.
Well, there is one that comes to mind, the
very same Shy Guy story that sent us on this
particular streak of pitting it against the
Giga Chad in the first place.
But what if we put them together?
Would coming across a refined SCP-096 spell
the end for the Giga Chad?
Or would the muscular, masculine meme undo
the Shy Guy’s previous happy ending?
Well, according to the Anom-O-Tron 6000, neither.
When we last left him, after being turned
into a handsome, nine-feet tall man, SCP-096
had just started going by the name David.
SCP-987, the Desire Camera, had been used
to photograph the refined Shy Guy.
It showed him holding hands with the Foundation
scientist responsible for his transformation,
who had studied the new and improved SCP-096
in great detail.
She had quite the understanding of him.
But perhaps the photograph from the Desire
Camera was more of a metaphor, and what SCP-096
– or David – really desired, wasn’t
specifically the researcher who’d studied
him, but a partner who understood him.
Someone to call an equal.
Enter the Giga Chad.
According to the calculations made by the
Anom-O-Tron, the embodiment of ultimate masculinity
– both strong and sensitive – came bursting
into the Foundation facility.
There, the moment he and David saw each other,
was like the meeting of an unstoppable force
and an immovable object.
Neither one rushed to solve their encounter
with violence.
Both the Giga Chad and SCP-096 appreciated
each other’s aesthetic appeal; both were
remarkably handsome, and one couldn’t bear
the thought of ridding the world of the other.
Instead…
it was love at first sight.
Both David, formerly known as SCP-096, and
the Giga Chad fell head over heels in love
with each other.
And looking at both, it was hard not to see
why.
They were a pair of fine, perfectly chiseled
fellas, and they instantly hit it off.
The newly established couple enjoyed each
other’s company, spending time in deep conversations,
SCP-096 introducing his new partner to his
friends at the Foundation, while Giga Chad
was comfortable within his own masculinity
to express his feelings towards David without
fear of judgment.
No relationship is perfect, of course.
For a short time, a sliver of David’s old
self re-emerged.
The Shy Guy in him worried that perhaps his
relationship with the Giga Chad was based
purely on both of their extreme good looks,
and was nothing more than superficial.
But being an embodiment of healthy, idealized
masculinity, the Giga Chad was able to sense
something was wrong with David.
And, rather than do the insecure thing of
letting it fester, he addressed it directly,
and they discussed the issue in a healthy,
mature, and constructive way.
Not just so they could put SCP-096’s worry
to rest, but so that both of them could further
strengthen their relationship, and grow as
people.
And, of course, Giga Chad wasn’t just attracted
to SCP-096’s refined good looks.
Far from being superficial, he recognized
that David was a complete person, beautiful
both inside and out, and loved him as a whole,
not just because they were both conventionally
attractive on the surface.
SCP-096 and the Giga Chad stayed together
for the rest of their lives or, as we decided
to name this fourth scenario from the Anom-O-Tron:
‘Happily Ever After’.
Now go and check out “CAN SCP-096 CHASE
ITS VICTIMS ACROSS THE MULTIVERSE?”
and “SCP-096 TALE A LESSON IN POWER” for
more SCP-096!